Hey,
what's going on as bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
Oh,
I almost passed out to you on that.
I'm just checking in.
I just see how your week's going.
How's it going,
man?
You're almost there.
You're almost to the weekend.
It's going to be your world again.
You're gonna get to do psy d side when you wake up.
Do side now.
[inaudible]
I said greatest fucking thing about Saturday morning.
You decide all right now I don't care if you got kids.
I don't care if you've got a wife.
You've got a husband in this day and I he,
you guys [inaudible] I need you to shut the fuck up.
You're not the boss of me.
It's sad.
Saturday I'm staying in this fucking bed.
I hear the kids crying,
sweetheart.
I am crying.
What do they cry?
They didn't want to fuck.
They're crying about,
Huh?
They downstairs.
You know.
Well,
what are,
what are they doing right now?
What are they crying about?
What toy to somebody want that?
Somebody else he edited it.
That's not a life or death situation.
I am going to lay in this fucking bed and I want to get up when I decide
that's what Saturday is all about.
Sanity and feeling you have on Saturday morning when you can basically do
whatever the fuck it is you want,
provided the woman in your life is afraid of you
joking.
You can do whatever it is the fuck you want to do.
All right.
That feeling right there,
that's the feeling that you should be working towards.
Okay.
That misery,
that Monday through Friday awaken,
I got away.
Glad I got to wake up cause I have,
cause I fucking,
I get an agreement with these people down the street that I have to be there and
they have to be able to see my face at this particular fucking time and I got to
trudge in here and do this fucking job.
However,
on staff,
you get to feel what it's like to be living your dream
acquainted.
You've gotta be thinking,
well bill,
I can't fucking lay in a bed all fucking,
you know,
Monday through Sunday.
How would I eat?
How would I eat that?
Right there is what handouts or for,
it's what?
Seven 11 to four you want to sleep in every day?
This is what you do.
You sit outside of seven 11 you make a little sign,
all right?
You don't write it on a nice piece of notebook paper.
You've got to write it on like a piece of trash you so people know that you're
struggling right now fucking with you.
Somehow you got,
you got to become self employed.
You got to work for yourself.
If you want that Saturday morning grant,
you're going to still be working on,
only get to work Monday through Friday when you're self employed,
you can work Monday through Sunday,
but you'll get up when you want to get up,
all right?
And you'll at least have that feeling of a little bit of control and freedom.
Then he can take it too far.
Like the ultimate Saturday.
I'll get up when the,
whoever the fuck I want to is that fatty cakes there in North Korea.
Okay.
And you can tell by his build,
that Guy Sleeps Til at least 11 every day.
You know,
I bet he has like kid pajamas,
doesn't he look like he would,
you know,
giant speed racer bed or some shit.
Something about him.
He seems very childish,
you know.
I Dunno.
You know what it is.
I bet he just,
because he was the,
the dictators son,
nobody ever picked on him,
but he looked in the mirror and he was like,
the only reason why they're not picking on me right now is because
if they did,
my dad would feed them naked to two wild dogs.
That's the only thing stopping them.
Yeah.
Look how fat I am.
Look at me just standing there looking at his hair.
Hairy hairless fucking torso.
Right.
I bet he's getting any right.
Some manhole.
Fucking level.
Any,
there's some whole enemy's trying to fill.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
How about those Cleveland Goddamn Indians.
21 victories in a row.
You're never going to see this again.
I,
that's fucking amazing.
That is really amazing.
Um,
and how great would it be to see them and there wasn't,
was it 1948 they ended it this year?
I don't know about my red sox.
I don't know.
I'm going to keep saying that hope and I jinxed them into coming together.
I kind of fucking fell out of love with this team.
I've said it before when they fucking yelled at Eckersley I was like,
come on.
There was no discipline about,
that's a hall of Famer.
You know what you do in a hall of famer walks in a room.
You shut the fuck up.
That's what you do.
And if he criticizes you,
you say,
okay,
fair enough.
I'll try it a little better.
Their sport.
Maybe ask for zoonotic.
Now you don't ask for his autograph.
You want to be professional.
You want,
if you want to act like you're,
you're,
you're in the same business.
You never asked for an autograph within the same industry.
Okay?
Don't ever forget that.
I've seen people do it.
It's an ugly,
ugly fucking scene.
I know a guy that fucking play golf in a celebrity fucking tournament,
right?
Why can't I ever type in my password and talk at the same fucking time?
It's unbelievable.
He played in the celebrity golf tournament and one of the guys in his force and
was actually a fan of his and then fucking hanging out the palling around.
Everything's going great.
And then when they would done at the end of the round,
he asked for a picture and the guy's face just dropped.
And that was it.
It was over.
He went from hanging out with that guy to be in back in the crowd,
thrown his panties at him.
What is my point?
My point is I like sleeping in on.
Um,
alright.
Let's see what's going.
I don't have anything to talk about today because I'm just stuck in a fucking
writer's room.
We just were doing the table read this morning for episode,
uh,
three Oh seven.
I can't be screaming like daughter's still sleeping.
My mom,
my wife's probably going to fucking kill me right now on say,
yeah.
Is there a reason why ever since Bill Clinton,
they just won't let somebody be president?
I really think you know what it is.
I think it's because of,
I think it's because of social media and 24 hours news networks and all of that
type of shit.
This is like CNN,
CNN who refuses to cover any,
anything about Hillary and the Democratic Party,
ignoring the votes during the primary inboxing out Bernie Sanders who actually
gotten more votes and then Hillary actually has the fucking balls to be like we
should do away with the electoral college.
Oh,
because the fuck over that you ran on Bernie Sanders then was done to you.
I've never seen such an entitled fucking person.
Everybody talks about how entitled Trump is.
And I'm not saying he isn't Jesus fucking Christ.
She really thought that that job was hers.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
It's unfucking believable.
Um,
all right.
It says Sean Spicer basically admitted that he was willing to lie for Trump.
Now,
what is shocking about that?
Do you think there was nobody in Obama's cabinet that was willing to lie for him
or bushes or Clinton's or first Bush or Reagan or Carter?
That's what happens.
Think about in your life,
there's people you're willing to lie for.
You know,
your buddy's fucking hammered behind the wheel.
The cop comes up,
you sit down,
officer,
he's,
oh,
he's fine.
He's only had a couple of,
you know,
you do that.
It's a friend,
Jesus fucking Christ and everybody fucking sitting here acting like the
president runs the country is fucking hilarious.
Like his decisions aren't decided
pie all the money that you fucking need to get in the fucking office.
Right?
I don't know.
They keep saying to Trump,
use most of his own money.
I doubt it.
I don't fucking know.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm just so fucking sick of people.
You know,
acting like this guy is way worse than the other guy because the two or three
issues other than that,
as far as the environment,
as far as the food supply,
as far as the heroin epidemic,
it's the exact same thing.
Don't fucking say shit about it.
Right?
Is that what it is?
I Dunno.
All right.
After Chicago,
Tj injury is found dead in a,
in hotel freezer.
Mystery lingers.
This is why I don't want you to think North Korea's latest nuclear tests so
powerful.
It reshaped the mountain above it.
Okay,
now we have,
what's nuclear power?
It's powerful.
Rush fires,
cruise missile at ISPD stronghold.
Is that the cool way to say Isis?
Now is I a stronghold in East Syria?
Russia is about to kick off a war game that is freaking out in NATO.
Here's what we know.
This is why I don't read the news.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't know any of this.
It's a game having a game.
They can't play a game in their own country.
Coordinated attack in southern Iraq kills at least 50
yeah.
Okay.
No good news yet.
All right,
let's go to the United States.
Let's see what good news is here.
Eight dead after South Florida nursing homes,
air conditioning fails following Hurricane Irma.
Great.
Next one,
as the White House calls for her firing,
ESPN is Jamelle Hill address the elephant in the room.
What the fuck is this?
How the fuck did we go from the White House to a reporter on ESPN?
Now this,
now this,
I'll tell you this here.
I got to read this one.
I got to read.
All right,
here we go.
Here we go.
What did we say?
How's hours after a White House spokesperson called for Espn to fire her because
she called president Trump a white supremacist on Twitter.
Jamil Hill or Jumel modal.
He'll tweet it about the topic Wednesday night saying she was going to address
the elephant in the room after becoming the latest flash point in a cultural
skirmish that is involved.
The sports network.
Once again,
hashtagging your tweets.
Hashtag facts hill wrote my comments on Twitter express my personal belief,
my regard,
my regret is that my comments at and the public way I made them painted ESPN in
an unfair light.
My respect for the company and my colleagues remains unconditional.
Yeah.
How the fuck do you have that job?
And No,
you can't tweet some shit like that.
You're going to get fired cause at the end of the day all ESPN gives a fuck
about is ratings in,
in,
in money.
That's what they care about.
Uh,
all right,
so when asked Wednesday afternoon by the Post David
Nakamura Nakamura,
that's a good last name.
Uh,
about hills original tweets.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said she was unsure whether the president was aware of
the kerfuffle they cause,
but at course he was aware of the guy fucking tweets every day.
It's like a seventh grade girl.
I think that's one of the more outrageous comments that anyone could make and
certainly something that I think is fireable offense by ESPN.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Oh,
give me a fucking break.
I love how ESPN thinks that reflects on them and all they is a cup of PBR or on,
you know,
further woo GC at a bar.
My President.
Oh,
I ain't gonna want to see if the Yankees beat the fucking Indians tonight.
Yes,
you are.
What else are you going to do?
Read a book.
It's a sports network.
This is some of the dumbest people on the planet.
My self included.
Do you how many times I've tried,
I've gotten so disgusted with the NFL.
I tried to walk away.
Then I just had to admit that I was too weak to do it.
I like how the NFL ratings are down now and they're trying to blame that stupid
Colin Kaepernick thing.
That's what it was.
Oh,
that's what w wasn't what,
you know what it was is they just got greedy.
I think it's the NFL plus it goes in cycles too.
You know what I mean?
It's like the NBA where they had bird magic into fucking,
uh,
Jordan and then there was a little bit of a lull there for a minute.
Right.
And then like a,
I dunno.
Yeah,
I guess the spurs weren't fucking exciting enough.
Um,
I dunno.
And then you know,
eventually you other guys came along,
Lebron came along.
Yeah,
the next one.
Right.
I think football goes to the same thing,
but the problem is that these fleet,
these guys in the NFL,
they're trying to go global and they're trying to a p like please,
as many people as humanly possible.
So they kind of abandoned their original family.
And you know where the NBA is right now.
The NBA is where you two was when Bono started wearing those big fly glasses,
the big mosquito glasses
and was saying shit like this is the most surreal night of my life,
man.
He started playing a character,
you know,
in eight years they went from in
carrying a fucking white flag and all,
whatever the fuck it is they were doing back then.
I was never the big youtube guy.
Okay.
As I told you before,
I didn't listen to the right music in the 80s.
I was listening to a crocus and Hellickson.
Yeah.
How's this in all those fucking beds?
You know what I mean?
And then I was watching sports and I was flunking math and French class.
I mean,
that's basically what you've been listening to all these years.
If you ever wondered,
um,
I don't need to go to ancestry.com to figure out my mystery.
Okay.
I am a fucking dope.
I am a dopes.
Dope.
When I walk into a room,
dopes shut up just to listen to what your stupid thing I'm gonna say.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
They fucking,
they,
they did the pink thing.
Let's have the football players were paying.
I love how,
like for some reason the fact that a football is a really male testosterone
aggressive thing that like for some reason guys have to apologize for that and
they just can't,
is that the word?
Feminate they can't make it like,
like feminine enough all of a sudden
cause all these feminist bitch moaning and complaining has all these
corporations all in a myth like,
oh we don't want to be considered sexist.
The next thing you know they're wearing pink for a month is if the NFL gives a
flying fuck
about anything other than making money.
Cancer.
This is what we care about.
Your brain Terman into scrambled eggs.
Yeah,
we don't get,
and you killing yourself by the time you're 50.
We don't give a fuck about that.
Oh,
is that what you did?
Here's 40 bucks for everybody who ever played the fucking game.
They don't give a shit.
Um,
according to reports,
they kept like 95 to $97 for every hundred dollars he made off of that pink shit
.
So give me a fucking break.
They show people in the crowd that are in the military,
they charge that branch in the military.
They treat like a commercial as they tell you to support the troops.
The Fuck Outta here.
Right?
So now what?
So now all these women's groups sit there bitch moaning and complaining.
So now they got,
they got female referees,
they get women calling the games.
They got the guys wearing pink for an entire fucking month.
They got lady Gaga singing at the fucking halftime at the super bowl.
They took a total fucking left turn.
And when you do that like you to do is you're going to lose a lot of your
original fan base that are like,
hey man,
I liked him back when the boy,
I like the first day album,
I saw him when there was only 8,000 people at the fucking show.
That's basically what they're going through and they're going to survive it and
they're going to transition from,
you know,
the frozen Tundra and all of that fucking,
making it seem like it was fucking d day.
All of that great shit that I loved.
They are going to transition out of all of that.
And um,
I think that there's going to be a lot more futures in,
in teals and all that type of stuff coming into the NFL is they try to,
uh,
I dunno.
I think as they try to get ahead of this next generation of people that call
that's coming up that goes out to comedy clubs and literally just stares at the
comedians.
Like that's what I'm experiencing now.
I was at the comedy store last night.
Granted something fucked up happened before I went on stage.
I guess they should have realized that.
And uh,
they,
yeah,
just uh,
just staring at me
staring at me.
So I dunno.
I Dunno what I have to do.
You know,
I'm thinking of actually maybe I'll,
I'll start wearing pink on stage and then people will think that I care.
Um,
anyways,
I don't want to get,
I don't want to fucking,
I don't want to call out any fucking specific fucking people.
I don't want to fucking do that cause you know,
I sucked as a comedian eventually.
I got better at it,
but I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ.
If you're going to go down that road,
you still have to pick somebody that's of a fucking certain level of
professionalism though.
If you're going to have a fucking national game,
I mean Jesus Christ,
and I'm not talking about that poor bastard that froze like a deer in a
headlight
that fuck your kid on the side.
I just felt bad for that too.
You know what I mean?
But I'm just saying,
you know,
if you're going to call a fucking game,
good fuck it Lord.
Good Lord.
Um,
this is actually my dream.
My dream is somebody that like is like a fucking went to broadcasting school and
then you pair them up with someone that played the game.
I know they tried to do that all the time,
but someone that actually can tell a story that played the fucking gate,
that's when it's the best.
Like Collins Worth.
John Madden,
Phil,
I love a lot of people.
Didn't like Phil saying,
I love Phil Simms,
the Guy Fucking,
you won a super bowl.
He's the first guy to say,
I'm going to Disneyland.
I'm not going to listen to this guy.
All these guys who play fantasy football trying to say the guy doesn't know what
he's talking about.
Yeah.
What would he know about?
Well,
you know,
he only played the game professionally.
You fucking moron.
Um,
I dunno.
Wait a second.
What the fuck is going on here?
All right.
I don't know what the Hell I just did.
I had my recorder on the floor.
I don't know when the hell I just chopped it off,
but I had the thing recording on the wrong speed.
I Dunno what the fuck happened.
Anyways,
I don't fuck,
I don't know what's going on.
What's going on in comedy clubs.
And in the NFL,
I don't know what the fuck they're doing and this is just,
is just part of becoming old.
Like why do I got to put their street lights up so bright?
Like I'm just an old man.
Don't fucking listen to me.
Yeah.
Anyways,
I don't understand how I had a half hour to do this before nine o'clock.
And it's almost nine o'clock,
and I only have fucking 20 minutes done probably because I stepped on the
recorder and I
the fucking worst.
I'm the worst anyways.
So congratulations to the NFL.
I know you guys want to go global.
I hope you fucking do it.
Um,
you know,
I'm sure you're jealous of the UFC that started way after you guys and they were
able to do it.
You are sure.
Um,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
I Dunno what the fuck to tell you.
It's just like,
I don't,
I,
uh,
I kind of like college football.
I'm gonna start watching that and then eventually they're going to get pressure
to fucking make this game a male testosterone game.
For some reason.
We need a bunch of estrogen in it.
You know,
this is what I don't understand about women.
Okay.
Every study says that they're way smarter than men.
Right?
They can handle a stronger level of pain.
They're more in touch with their emotions.
They could do all of that shit.
And you know,
for them,
far as my experience goes,
I'd agree with it.
For the most part,
I dunno about the arrogant.
We're smarter than you.
It depends on what the fuck you talking about.
Right?
But I'll give you,
I'll give you all of that,
but at that's all true.
What if fuck kid,
you start your own sports league.
Why don't you do that?
Yeah.
What do you constantly have to fucking infiltrate some shit?
A bunch of guys doing some shit that you know,
at the end of the day you think it's fucking stupid.
It's a bunch of guys smashing into each other's scrambling.
They're fucking brains trying to get a ball crossed the fucking line to score
points.
You know,
you don't give a shit about that.
Why can't they come up with their own Goddamn fucking sports league and then
from top to bottom,
fucking can be all women.
Then you turn that thing into a global billion dollar fucking entity and then
women get all that fucking money.
There's your power,
fucking join a guy's league and then they give you a pink flags to throw holding
off offense.
Like,
why would you do that?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
I don't understand these things.
All I can,
all I can do is we equate it to my life is I can tell you this.
When I worked for somebody else,
let's see.
I like the fuck overs.
You can't,
you can't keep a,
you can't keep track of them.
That's when you get stolen from the most.
That's when you dream gets crushed the most.
When you fucking work for somebody else.
If you work for yourself,
you have more control.
Granted,
you work way more hours,
but that's the price you pay.
We're taking collars.
Um,
all right.
Let me read a little bit of advertising here.
Everybody.
Um,
by the way,
a fucking oh Billy,
no fun,
no booze.
28 days,
28 days a week.
I don't fucking booze.
I stare at the ceiling,
tried to go to sleep.
Oh,
I loved that whiskey.
It's my Tylenol pm.
Um,
speaking of which,
this is going to be the biggest test for my air quotes.
Sobriety.
I'm not fucking sober.
I'm just not drinking.
Okay.
All right.
This is the biggest test.
Saucy thoughtfully me.
Y'All guys saucy.
Everyone at some point has wished they could just have beer,
wine,
or liquor delivered.
Well,
someone finally decided to do something about it.
Oh my God.
I love these people.
Next,
please mention all the talking points below.
Dude,
I'll fucking sing these if you want to.
Want me to.
Introducing thoughts.
See me out.
The alcohol delivering app thought they around or delivers your favorite wine
and beer and liquor right to your door on demand.
It's Uber for alcohol.
This is great.
This is fucking great.
Uber's great,
right?
I should say lift cause they fucking advertise on us,
Oh,
I love those.
Those those guys at Lyft and the ladies,
right?
They fucking,
yeah,
they cut down on drinking and driving.
Right now they're going to cut down on fucking ruin in the ozone layer.
Well I guess some stores to drive liquor store,
drive it over to you.
Whatever.
All I know is you're not in the street,
dude.
You turn your fucking apartment into the club.
You never leave.
They never shut you off.
This is great.
Okay.
Now,
if you're in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego,
away,
whale's Vagina or Sacramento,
you're thought the order will arrive at your door in 30 minutes or less.
Ready to drink.
All right guys.
Now,
La,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego,
Sacramento,
you've got to fucking drink up.
You've got to get these people the money that they need to expand.
All right,
for the right,
this is like the original six except as five cities first,
okay?
For the rest of us thought that will deliver beer,
wine,
and liquor to your door in two days or less nationwide.
There are no minimums,
no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you've got the saucy APP around,
now you've got a fully stocked bar on your phone and for a limited time you can
start drinking top shelf booze now cause you're not going out paying a cover and
or any of that type of shit.
Okay?
You go out,
you're fucking rub one out at home.
Okay?
You just hate no,
no more hitting on chicks.
Right?
And maybe buy that fucking robot doll that came out last year for 10 grand that
you can bang that eventually Joe Rogan was tweeting that you can fucking hackers
can hack into it and teach it to kill Ya.
Three scary days coming up.
Um,
anyways and for a limited time you can get $15 off your download.
Oh when you download the saucy APP and enter Promo Code Bird,
that saucy meow app spelled s a u c e y honey and enter Promo code birth for $15
off.
Gets the saucy app today and use Promo Code burn a write draft kings everybody.
Week one is in the books but it's,
it's not too late to get closer to the game you love called crawl right up the
ass crack of the NFL with draft kings one week fantasy football.
This Sunday draft kings is hosting a $100,000 degenerate gambler.
Pick him contest that is totally free to enter.
Pick them is the newest way to play one week fantasy football.
Drafting your team as a fan is faster than ever.
Draft Kings has organized players into eight tiers.
All you have to do is select one player from each tier.
Choose between the public,
uh,
choose between public contests with big cash prizes or private contests where
you can compete against a group of your friends.
Draft kings also has beginner and casual contests where you play against people
of a similar skill level.
The best part is you get to draft a new team each week without any commitment.
So get draftkings.com now and use Promo Code Burr to play in draft kings free
contest with a $100,000 drop top dollars in total prizes this Sunday.
Use My Promo Code [inaudible] to play for free this Sunday.
That's Promo Code
burr@draftkings.com eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
Oh,
look who's back.
Everybody's simply think the average property lost from just one home breaking
is too fucking grand.
$2,316.
Jesus,
these people did their homework or they made up a really great fake number.
If you tally all the burglaries in your country,
the total loss is in the billions.
Simply safe.
Home security protects every door and window in your home,
but not the skylife.
That's a window.
Yes.
Right.
Okay.
Home secure.
You get motion sensors,
entry sensors.
Tom Cruise couldn't fucking break into this place.
Simply safe system is completely wireless.
You can set it up yourself with simply safe's.
There's no longterm contracts or hidden fees and you have professed a
professional alarm monitoring your place around the clock,
ready to send the police.
That's just 15 bucks a month.
Come on people.
Go to simply say [inaudible] dot com and get a special 10% discount when you
order today or if you want this secure security system right away,
visit your local best buy that simply saved [inaudible] dot com for 10% off
simply safe bird.com.
All right,
two more.
Hang in there.
All his shave club,
dude,
when you might not know,
what you might not know is that dollar shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the bathroom.
Body Wash,
shampoo,
Hair Gel,
lip balm,
everything I've been to bodywash or shampoo,
hair,
Gel,
lip balm at the store.
There are too many options.
I can't figure it out and you can't tell the difference between any of them.
How dumb are you?
Then if you have any questions to clerk usually doesn't know the difference or
there's just one fucking person work in their cvs or can't really help you sense
they are not experts on the products.
College dropouts,
dollar Shave Club makes it easy and convenient for you to upgrade your shave and
your bathroom.
Now you don't have to step foot in a store and get a hike to get a high quality
eye kit.
What happened?
I can't read anymore.
Now you don't have to step foot in a store to get a high quality shave and
grooming products.
Dollar Shave Club's delivers them right to your fucking door.
They go in there and they're high fiving the people that thought the me out,
just like a red,
their razors.
Everything is super high quality and we'll leave you looking and feeling amazing
if you're sick of nonsense of the nonsense.
At the store.
Now is the time to try out dollar shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower shave started kit to new members for only $5.
This started set features,
the executive razor and three trial versions,
three trial size versions of the most popular products that help you stay fresh
and clean.
Um,
so fresh.
It's so clean.
If your first box in your first box you will receive their shave butter bodywash
and one wipe Charlies.
Oh chary but wipes.
Um,
you will also receive the executive razor which includes their premium,
weighty handle and focused set of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a
month.
This offers exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash [inaudible] that's
dollar shave club.com/bar hey dollar shave club's high quality products have you
covered from face cheeks,
the budgets.
There is no better time to try the club.
Oh look who's here.
Everybody.
Oh Jesus.
Here we go.
Dodo due to me on days me undies.
What happened to the NFL Doo doot doot me on days.
Me undies.
I think it go into the hell.
Why'd he got gotta please.
Everybody just have people's passion to each other.
Who Cares?
Why do you have to have a bunch of pink,
a bunch of fucking ladies there?
You know it's a guy sport because we won a theme.
Progressive.
Alright me undies.
Um,
and if you send a feminist,
a dick pic that it has that,
but you have it in a little pink sweater.
Is that okay?
Is that considered a
progressive?
I don't know.
All right.
[inaudible] you want to look good in your underwear,
don't ya?
You want to be comfortable,
right?
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies.com and find the best pair of underwear in the world world.
Talk about why me undies is the best underwear you'll ever own.
You know what I love about it?
They send it to me if two for free,
nice and snug up against my nuts.
You know what I mean?
But it's affectionate.
It's not suffocating.
Makes my nuts feel safe.
And you know,
I gotta be honest with you,
before I met me undies,
I never felt that before.
Beyond these will be the most comfortable pair of underwear you will own made
from a sustainably sourced naturally soft fabric that's three times softer than
cotton.
Right now me on,
he's has an executive,
has an exclusive offer for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free shipping and me undies is so sure you'll
love their underwear.
They even offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You order a pair and if you don't love your first pair,
get the get a full refund.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
What in the fuck are you waiting for to get your 20% off free shipping and their
100% satisfaction guarantee and get the best and softest underwear you will ever
own.
Go to me and he's dot com slash [inaudible] this is limited time offer.
So what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life evidently according to the copy.
It's time to let me on these change.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr right now.
Okay.
That's the podcast I got to go do the table read for episode three Oh seven.
Um,
which means season three,
episode seven,
which I never understood.
I used to be like,
well,
we're not on episode 307,
um,
uh,
great computer falls to the floor.
That just probably woke up.
My daughter is there.
My daughter down there,
I'm sorry.
This thing was so rushed and jumbled up.
Um,
but I'm under time fucking thing here so I'm not going to keep babbling about
it.
Enjoy the music.
Uh,
a half hour of greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from Thursday.
Gone by in a year.
Gone past or maybe it's from earlier this year.
I don't know.
It's sems
watching
sometimes
stone
Cleo Clarine
go
on the box.
Frank Sinatra.
Oh,
by the way,
is I'm all over the fucking map here.
Did you fucking see that?
Shameless fucking Hillary Clinton
trying to pander to get the African American vote.
She's on some radio show.
I just watched the clip.
I had to shut it off.
Forgive me.
I don't know what radio show it is,
but she's sitting there and she goes and she's trying to get the black vote and
she,
they asked you what's something you always carry around with you?
And she said,
hot sauce.
Yeah.
What a fun.
They,
the Clintons are the fucking,
I swear to God.
Can't you just see both of them on a used car lot to one of those cheesy local
commercials?
Do they are the fucking devil.
Okay.
I remember when Hillary Clinton ran for fucking,
uh,
Senate after eight years of being in the White House,
the fucking Yankees had won four world series.
She never showed up,
never said a fucking thing.
And then all of a sudden she's running for fucking a Senate in New York,
shows up with a brand new Yaggie hat and goes,
I valley's very Yankee Fan and had this big grin.
Like I said it now they're going to like me.
This is how out of touch she is.
She literally thinks that.
She just has to say,
I carry around hot sauce.
Okay.
And I'll,
I'll black people going to be like,
oh shit.
Oh,
I can relate to that.
What's she gonna do next?
You get to go to fucking China town,
which I always carry around soy sauce.
Yeah.
We can go down south.
You know,
I love guns and my cousins,
sorry,
I shouldn't have said that.
Um,
hot rods.
I've always liked hot rods.
Fucking shameless.
This is the thing about like,
when you're at her level of fucking wealth,
which is really you,
I don't know how you explain it.
You know,
when her husband,
you know,
had the highest office in public office and you will,
he is president,
you only make four,
500 grand a year.
Somehow they through their daughter a $3 million wedding.
I mean,
how does the math work there?
Yeah.
They had the fuck she is the fucking devil.
I'm telling you.
You know,
oh my God,
what a fucking selection this year.
Can you fucking believe this shit?
A reality show star.
Yeah.
You know who's sitting there with that fucking,
I don't know what the other guy's name is.
Then talking about the size of their hands.
They haven't had did size.
He addict debate running for office.
You got Hillary.
You fucking write it.
I'll say it.
She doesn't give a fuck.
This is why I gotta be honest with you.
Why I like Republicans better than Democrats because the Republicans at least
have the decency to just show,
to openly show you that they don't give a fuck about you and Democrats,
they actually try to act like they give a fuck how people,
but people that work for a fucking living,
they don't do the same fucking people.
They just lie about it.
You know?
I swear to God,
if Bernie Sanders would just fucking go the whole way,
you know what I mean?
Don't stop and Kuwait,
you gotta go all the way to Baghdad with these fucking bankers.
Okay?
That's what you gotta do.
You gotta tip over the statute when you got to have all those top level bankers
swinging at the end of a rope.
That's the only way to stay.
You got to start over again.
That's my candidate.
None of them are saying that.
So it,
it's over.
And I know you'd think it built,
you don't know shit.
And you read conspiracy theory and you know what I say to that?
You're absolutely right.
Okay.
All right,
let's move on.
That was,
uh,
that was,
that was political comedy right there.
A few.
If you're wondering what that was supposed to be,
she goes to little Italy.
What do you always have in your purse?
A jar of Marinara sauce.
Who's your favorite singer?
Dean Martin.
Oh my God.
Did you see the house?
She looked like she rolled her eyes.
I don't want to put like shit on her.
That's what she fucking did.
Okay.
That's how out of touch she is.
Hillary Clinton thinks black.
All black people walk around with hot sauce in their purse because white people
don't know how to season food.
Um,
I'm not saying there aren't some black people did do that.
You know what I mean?
But that would also be people who aren't white,
who look at white people and think we're all in the upper 1% standing on a yacht
shooting the shit with one of the Kennedy's and they're fucking weird in Brent
inbred dentition.
I never understood the Kennedys.
I,
they,
they're from Mike the nose up.
They're really good looking people,
great hair,
you know,
nice fucking big five head,
it looks great on TV,
decent eyes,
you know,
and then you just get to that for you get to those,
those,
I mean it was getting old.
They look like from the nose down,
they look like Clint Howard.
I don't know what it is.
There's something going on with that family.
You can't,
uh,
okay.
You know what it is,
is they still look ethnic.
They feel,
look at,
um,
if you look at like,
like white people from like,
like look at Joe Dimaggio,
you know,
he's probably considered a good looking guy.
That guy is fucking deck.
I Dunno what happened once everybody got all mixed up.
Like all the fucking national,
I was getting mixed up like,
you know,
started streamlining the looks and people are way better looking now.
Don't you think then when you look back in the day,
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
Babe Ruth,
every once in Lou Gehrig was a good looking guy.
You know what I mean?
But Babe Ruth,
that was a mess.
Joe Dimaggio mess.
I can say what?
Don't bad looking.
I don't know.
I'm just saying when you look at the shit back then,
like an Italian guy looked a hundred percent fucking attack.
I don't want to,
you know something.
And when I went to Italy,
they will better look in the back then,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
We allegedly had better food back then.
People were shorter.
I don't know what it was.
Did you ever notice that when you look back and when you really look at those
old pictures?
I love looking at old pictures and it's like that George Carlin bit,
when you look at it on picture and you're like,
everybody in that picture is dead.
And for some reason in a morbid way,
it's like fascinating.
When I look at those old pictures,
I just,
that's what I think.
Like God damn it.
There was some fucking ugly ass people,
you know,
and you know,
it was a game changer was uh,
three things.
Polio,
vaccine,
penicillin and braces.
Those three fucking things could just hide so many fucking imperfections.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And once you get braces,
Jesus Christ,
if you just brush your fucking teeth in remotely,
keep yourself in shape.
You know,
you throw on some nice clothes.
People have no idea where you came from.
You know,
back in the day,
people,
they saw it on your teeth,
told the whole fucking store.
You just smile and be like,
hi,
I can see you're going to have tuberculosis.
You live in a damp Dag fucking apartment with no fucking windows.
You saw it in their fucking teeth.
Right.
I don't know about,
I heard what's his face?
Jp Morgan had like Rosacea.
Is that how you say it all over his face?
He was just all fucking angry.
Those old school rich guys,
you know,
used to walk around with top hats like the Penguin Horn,
right when I'm walking down the street.
Um,
is this a podcast anymore?
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Let me,
let me do some advertising here and then I'll uh,
I'll get to more babbling here in a moment.
All right.
Hot Sauce.
Ah,
shameless fucking shameless.
She looks in,
bred her fucking teeth.
There's something going on with her and the sub go with you see how Bill Clinton
collapse now it's like he's a,
like a marionette puppet.
He has his mouth open.
Uh,
that's how he made it.
But that smiling with his mouth open.
Oh,
I've got to fix it.
I'll fix everything.
How are you doing?
Call me later.
Oh
Huh.
Oh,
friend
[inaudible].
Oh,
I'm sick of Obama's wife.
This is some Republican rants either.
It's just kind of first ladies in general,
you know,
I don't know what it is all throughout my life with each presidency,
like these first ladies,
they've just gotten more and more like,
like,
uh,
like chatty,
you know,
more.
More chime in in like leaning into the frame,
fitting out their ideas.
It's just like,
well,
why are you talking?
Right?
You weren't elected.
Shut up.
Your husband's not running a lemonade stand here.
He's running the country.
You don't just Shyman
let me guess.
Is this considered sexist?
Why can you just nodded their leg?
Let me ask you this.
All right.
Let's say you had a leak in your house.
Okay?
You call a plumber up.
He shows up and he goes,
yeah,
I took the leaks coming from the upstairs bathroom.
We need to shut it off.
Then all of a sudden his wife walks in.
Who is it?
A plumber.
Okay.
Why don't you be like,
with all due respect,
shut the,
I need a plumber in this moment.
[inaudible] sending all of branch here.
All right.
At some point there's going to be the first female president,
right?
Exactly.
At that moment.
You're going to have the first male first lady,
right?
When that happens,
that too needs to shut his trap.
I don't want to hear a word out of him.
I want to hear from the president.
You,
sir,
go do some first lady stuff.
All right.
Get yourself some gloves that go up to your elbows.
Smile and nod during speeches.
Go put your own flair.
Redecorated the White House.
Hi,
I'm Michelle Obama right now.
She's sitting there holding up those hashtags from that Hashtag bring back our
girls.
It's like,
I blew my mind.
why are you showing me that?
I'm a stand up comedian,
like what am I going to do to get those curls back?
Why don't you look across the dinner table?
It's like you see that
[inaudible] that is the leader of the free world.
Tell them to pick up a phone,
call
some navy seals and solve it.
Well,
what am I going to do?
the sharpen Mike [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible].
I'll tell you what kills me.
Hillary Clinton might run.
She might.
She might run that.
That blows my mind.
I mean on,
she became a senator.
She went from being the president's wife to be in a senator just like that
lateral move.
That's like Tom Brady's wife become the next quarterback of the ramps.
It's like what?
Yeah,
hanging out.
You just pick it up.
I stopped in sports and then I bank Tom Brady and I don't know what happened.
I just picked up a ball.
I started liking it.
I'm leading receivers was incredible.
[inaudible]
I knew it was going to be like this.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn.
This is the Monday morning podcast on Monday,
September 14th,
2009.
Um,
it's like fucking 10 20 at night.
I finally got some time to do the podcast today.
I was flying back from Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania.
I lost my cell phone.
You know,
once again,
I lost another cell phone.
Every time I get a nice cell phone,
I lose him.
So I just reactivated my little flip phone.
Those of you who go on to bill.com when you listen to my podcast,
you see that picture of me right there.
Okay.
Looking down at the bar and that little 15 year old chicks flip phone that I got
there.
That's what I'm back to.
I went from a blackberry to that thing,
you know,
just once I would like to lose a fucking phone and call it and if someone on the
other end be my savior,
be like,
why?
Yes,
yes.
I have found your phone and I would love to return it to you.
There is nothing more I would like to do.
The return is you now free of charge,
free of charge.
That's what happens.
Everybody else,
I know,
he told my girlfriend loses her cell phone.
She calls up,
she just,
you know,
oh my God,
I left my cell phone and then she just picks up Mike.
She goes,
let me use your phone.
And then she just goes,
you know,
rings like twice and it's always the nicest person ever on the other line.
She's like,
Hey,
yeah,
it is my thank you.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Okay,
great.
I can write and then I'm driving her somewhere to go pick the fucking thing up.
That never happens for me.
It just rings and rings and rings.
And then I just hear my voicemail,
hey,
this is bill.
You've reached my cell phone that you're never going to fucking see again.
Please leave a message and you might want to call variety,
you know,
call fucking Verizon and have shutoff is for somebody calls Trinidad on this
goddamn thing.
Fuck.
So that was my day.
This is how old I am too.
You know what?
When I was flying out here,
there was a,
there was nobody sitting next to me and actually was fell asleep,
you know,
laying down on the row.
And when I woke up,
like I felt like my lower body dislocated from my upper body.
It wasn't even like my back hurt.
It was just like I fell.
He got hit by a fucking car.
It's been a brutal day is what I'm trying to say people,
but maybe we can in Philly was awesome.
So many people showed up so people showed up.
We added a show.
That's never happened to me,
you know?
So I want to thank everybody.
Before I get going on this long rambling podcast here,
I want to thank everybody in Philadelphia.
Came out to see me.
I had a great time and I was working there with the Joe to Rosa,
the a teen idol,
the new hot shot teen idol on the opiate Anthony Show was opening up for me.
And uh,
all my God did the Raiders just score a fucking touchdown is a no flag.
Holy Shit.
Are they finally going to beat the charges?
Okay.
I don't want to ruin you guys.
Who Anybody Tivo the fucking game.
They just went up 1917 with two 34 left.
You know,
it's funny,
I was supposed to have a bet,
you know,
I'm a patriots fan and I was supposed to bet these guys shred and Reagan out in
Buffalo,
right?
I made him a $50 bet last year when Tom Brady went down that they are patriots
are going to make the playoffs because they were saying that they were done.
So if the Patriots didn't make the playoffs,
I own both 50 bucks.
But if I won,
they had to read a written apology to bill Belicheck that I wrote and they had
to read it on the air.
We went 11 and five but we didn't make it.
So I owed them 50 bucks,
but I never went to buffalo and I can never pay him.
So Lo and behold,
the first game of the season,
we're playing buffalo.
So I go,
hey,
let's go double or nothing,
you know,
and they wouldn't touch it.
They would not touch the fucking game on air.
I was like,
dude,
the worst you could do is break even.
And then they still,
they still wouldn't back their own team and look at the fucking game.
They actually almost won it.
They actually did win it.
They just blew the game.
But uh,
so I'm glad,
I'm glad I saved myself.
50 bucks each shred and Reagan,
if you're listening to this,
you guys pumped out.
And you know,
it's funny was when I got off the plane,
I actually got a message from one of the guys that works there trying to get me
to call in at the last second.
I bet a lot of their listeners called them punks for not taking the bed.
And uh,
unfortunately I lost my cell phone or I would've called in,
but it worked out for me.
Um,
I'm too fucking frazzled to do this guys.
I really am.
I can't fucking do this,
but I got to get this done because I got too much shit to do tomorrow usually.
And I enjoy doing the podcast.
It's usually in the morning.
I'm usually screaming and I'm having a good fucking time,
but now it's late.
My dog's asleep.
My downstairs neighbors asleep downstairs neighbor doesn't like us.
We have hardwood floors and my girlfriend has high heel shoes.
So you can do the math on that one.
Let's just get,
let's just cut to the chase.
You guys mind if I do a short one this week?
Yeah.
Well to fucking bed.
Um,
let me,
let me give you some happy shit because this isn't going to be happy.
I'm fucking exhausted.
Let me give you some youtube videos to watch this week.
All right.
This first one,
um,
I stumbled across because someone else showed me something else.
Um,
this video which you want to searches,
it says,
try not to laugh or say
WTF.
Basically what the fuck.
But you just write WTF all lowercase.
Try not to laugh or say WTF and I'm have a feeling a lot of women won't find it
funny because it's just really like you'd have to be in the seventh grade or a
mail to find this funny.
I can't even explain while it's why it's funny,
but it just makes me laugh my ass off.
But it's,
it's a great video cause you will either laugh or you will say,
what the fuck?
Um,
here's another one.
Somebody sent me a search,
gay top gun.
You guys ever seen the movie top gun and you've seen Tarantino going his rent
that it's actually a homo erotic movie.
The way this person edits it is fucking hilarious and a,
I haven't seen the movie.
Oh my God,
I probably am seeing that movie since the late eighties.
You know,
I remember I did.
I see in the movie theaters now.
I think somebody bought it.
Somebody,
my family bought that movie that was actually considered a good movie.
You know,
and uh,
you know,
we had it on VHS so you know,
the usual life of a VHS tape,
it lasted like a fucking year then it was all screwed up from being rewound,
you know,
so I haven't seen that basically since sort of 89 or 90 and uh,
I got to go with Tarantino on that one.
At least the way this Guy Ed is some movie man.
It's fucking,
it's really funny.
All right.
The last youtube video you might want to check out.
And this one and I'm just search a dance kick baby.
All right.
Comedian,
last night while I worked at very funny guy told me to uh,
Jeff and I've already forget his last fucking name.
I'm such a moron.
He was hilarious.
So,
uh,
he told me to check this one out.
Dance kicked baby.
Um,
it's,
I can't say it's funny.
It,
it'll definitely make you put your hand over your mouth.
Um,
cause it's not dance kicked baby.
It's not that it's dancing and then a baby gets kicked.
All right.
You want to have anyone see what happens when a toddler gets fucking,
just check it out.
All right.
There's a lot of sick fucks are going to look at that one first.
Um,
like I said,
this is going to be real economical,
economical,
whoever the fuck you say at this week.
Uh,
let's plow ahead.
Here's some advice somebody wants.
Listen to this story.
This one really a,
this one really grabbed me here on a lot of levels.
All right,
bill asked bill a bill.
I was at a family birthday party today when some friends of mine,
friends of my dad's showed up with their smoking hot daughter,
uh,
make after making a few glances at each other.
I figured I had a good chance of getting her number.
I went over to her,
my dad introduced us,
we made a little small talk.
Her mom then asked if she wanted a piece of cake or anything.
So I decided to be a fucking gentleman and offered to get her a piece.
So I come back with the slice of cake in hand only to see my brother.
And he's written this in capital letters,
so you know,
this isn't going to go anywhere good.
He goes,
I come back only to see my brother,
capital letters talking to her,
um,
and already getting her number on the guys that she's interested in getting into
law enforcement and he happens to be a cop.
Uh,
that pretty much canceled me out since there's no way I was going to pull the
same shit in which both brothers ask her for her number.
Yeah,
that would've been creepy.
So he goes,
uh,
I handed the cake and the three of us talk some more until her parents decided
to leave since it was towards the end of the party already.
Um,
after that,
after they left,
I immediately told my brother,
you know,
walked up to my brother and I told him what the fuck.
Since everybody could tell I was trying to get our number.
He joked along with my,
what does that u n d e s
I don't know what that word means.
Um,
he drew all my uncles.
I couldn't read that.
Sorry.
This volumes up way too high.
Here.
Let me turn this thing down.
Sorry.
Um,
record level.
I don't know.
I don't know how to fucking do that on the fly to it.
Does that work?
That's better.
Hello?
No,
it's still fucked up.
All right.
Whatever.
I'll hold the mic away from me.
Told you guys,
this one's going to be brutal.
I'm exhausted.
Um,
anyways,
so egos.
Yeah.
So I went up to him.
I said,
what the fuck?
Since everyone could tell I was trying to get her number.
He joked along with my uncles saying she's 26 and uh,
I guess he's 20.
And his brother,
the cop is 21.
So he choked her with his uncle,
said,
come on man,
she's 26.
She's out of your league.
And that he beat me to it.
I figured,
yeah,
I guess he did and didn't.
Uh,
so I did make a big deal or anything after that.
Since I'm not a little bitch,
who's going to cry about it?
I'm going to cry about some torts number.
However,
I still thought it was fucked up.
If it had been the other way around,
I would've just let my brother do his thing.
I guess it comes down to the bar scene where if you step away to get a bitch a
drink,
you're leaving the field pretty much open for anybody else.
I don't know.
Do you think it was a fucked up move or just part of the game?
Uh,
thanks and hope to see you on stage soon.
Um,
well what do I think about that?
Ah,
all right.
I don't want to blame the victim here,
but what I learned in that letter is that your brother's kind of a dick.
You know,
it's kind of a Dick move and uh,
you know,
I wouldn't have done that to my brother,
but you know,
he's doing it to you that that's,
that's a dick move and you live with the guy so you know he's a Dick.
You know what I mean?
And you kind of answered the question.
Yeah.
You never,
you never leave.
First of all,
even if you know,
even if he didn't come over,
you're already setting up the relationship that you know,
you're just going to be fetching her stuff,
offering her,
you know,
or you call,
do you want me to get you a blanket?
You know,
you don't wanna be that guy.
You know
your brother.
I don't know.
I really want to make fun of the fact that he went to law enforcement a,
let me teach you how to be a cop.
All right?
This is how your Frist,
somebody,
you know,
but believe me,
you use what you got.
You think I have never met her fucking good looking girl.
And I said,
uh,
you know,
worked away in that I was a comedian and an invited her to his show her in one
of her friends hoping desperately she would only show up by herself so I could
try and fucking banger.
So I can't get mad at him for that.
Um,
yeah,
in the future I would just,
I just wouldn't do that shit around your brother.
That's a really asshole thing and I think you need to get them back somehow.
I want to,
I want a story of revenge from you.
That's what I want.
But at the end of the day,
do the chicks fucking 26 years old and you know,
she's got a 21 year old trying to figure out our future,
you know,
she's a loser and plus,
just the way you were talking about it,
you know,
I learned a,
you never leave a bitch alone.
He just wanted to fuck her anyways.
Right.
So whatever lesson learned,
lesson learned and to use the top gun analogy,
your brother is now,
he's not a wing man.
He's not a good wing.
So fuck that guy.
And uh,
I dunno,
you know what she could do,
this is something I used to do way back in the day when I was in Boston and I
used to go to this place,
daisy Buchanan's on Newbury street,
which was a total fucking meat market and I'm sure it's still is.
I used to go in there with a,
with a couple friends of mine and you know,
going there,
you know,
I have a couple of drinks and just start talking shit to girls or whatever.
Trying to fucking hook up cause God knows that's easy to have three guys.
That's always a nice magic number.
No wonder we never hooked up.
But we used to go in there
and I forgot what you call it,
dropping bombs.
I can't remember what it was,
but basically you wouldn't cock block,
but she would definitely fuck with your friend.
If he was,
you'd see them hitting on a girl and it was going well.
You'd walk up to them and you would just make up some detail about his life.
That would be embarrassing,
that he would have to somehow play off.
Um,
unless she got serious.
And you really got mad.
Like a buddy of mine did one time and mentioned that a friend of mine was still
living in the basement with his mom.
That's what he said.
He had just got done striking out.
So then he came walking up all hammered and he's like,
Oh yeah,
this guy was,
fuck this guy was one of these dudes.
You know all those guys who like who look up at the ceiling when they talk.
And he was one of those guys and he just came walking up and that's what he
said.
He goes,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
you like this guy.
Hey did you mentioned that you still live at home with your parents?
He said it really angry.
You know what else this guy did?
That's a classic story.
I can't believe we never fucking told us we were in days if we can is one night.
Right.
And it was just one of those nights,
you know,
I dunno what we would talk in.
The women were responding,
we were like,
Holy Shit,
this is going great full once because believe me,
we did not do well.
There's a reason I had to get on a stage and act like a jackass.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I don't know what happened.
Met this group of girls and it was going great and we're all having a good time.
And everybody kind of paired off,
everybody was vibing,
right?
And um,
all of a sudden you just felt the whole energy,
energy of the bar just look towards the front door,
who was like somebody,
you know,
famous or something was going on.
You know,
like when all of a sudden there's like a commotion,
everybody just looks in that direction,
right?
So it was weird.
Everybody just sort of collectively looked at the doors like a wave that went
across the room every second.
Everybody felt the energy just looked in the direction you felt the energy
coming from.
And we look over at the door and I swear to God,
what the fuck just happened?
San Diego just scored Jesus Christ.
Fucking Raiders.
God Damn fucking guys.
Just can they ever be San Diego?
All right,
let me plow ahead.
So they fucking,
um,
everybody just goes and looks at the door and we look over and there's this guy
dressed like Elvis
fucking Elvis impersonator.
This is the most bizarre cock block I have got this guy standing of course like
fat Elvis,
some comic did that joke.
Nobody,
nobody ever dresses up like the in shape Elvis because no one was ever that good
look.
And they always dress like the fat one or something like that.
Right?
So everyone is it fat Elvis,
he's got the fucking,
you know,
right before he overdosed on pills,
sunglasses on,
and he was doing all these moves to whatever music was on.
Okay.
And uh,
he fucking like,
every girl in the bar was like,
oh my God,
they all fucking ran over to the guy.
Right?
So it was like everything was going great.
We're thinking we're going to hook up and next thing you know,
fucking fake.
Elvis walks in and the girls just runaway and they all run up to the guy because
they all want to get like their picture taken with them.
A fucking whatever Chevy guy in the bar were kind of stand like,
I'll duty you.
Fuck you.
Gotta be kidding me.
Right.
Tell my buddy who looks up at the ceiling he has,
he walks up to the guy,
you know,
and the guy standing up to and meeting.
Everybody will show up,
man.
How you doing?
All right.
Taking care of business.
How are you doing buddy?
He like doing the Elvis sing.
He's got the fucking leg shaking and everything.
So my buddy goes up there,
right?
And he starts shaking the guy's hand.
He's like,
what's up man?
And my buddy's like squeezing his hand,
right?
And he's looking up at the ceiling.
Yeah,
but the fake Elvis can tell he's pissed.
He's like,
well,
what's the mind of man?
And my body's just like,
he goes,
hey dude,
because like squeeze in his hand.
He goes,
hey buddy,
why can't you just be yourself?
You know,
it's like looking up the sale cause why can't you just be yourself?
You know?
He goes,
I like the red sox.
I don't come in here dressed like Roger Clemens and the guys that go in,
he's kind of dropping character going,
all right,
man.
All right,
dude.
All right.
All right,
look,
his voice is changing and they start having this fucking handshake fight,
squeezing each other's hands and they were about ready to go at it.
And at that point I was like,
I was going to see the greatest thing ever because my buddy was big.
I was like,
if he fucking punches this fake Elvis and I see those plastic glasses helicopter
off of his fucking face,
ah,
please let them be wearing a wig.
And right before they did it was like you ever see like a Nhl game when the ref
steps in right before two goons are gonna go at it.
The guy fucking broke it up,
but it was still good.
My buddy had a fucking handshake fight without Elvis and press Personator.
It really just broke the guy down.
That's what I loved.
Everyone is like,
oh my God,
Elvis,
what's going on?
I thought you died.
No,
my end,
I'm always alive.
He's just playing along.
Oh my God.
Let me get a picture of it.
Okay honey,
you know he's doing all that shit and then my buddy just comes up.
Hey Dude,
why can't you just be yourself?
Ah,
fuck.
Those were some drunk days.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
What the fuck was I talking about?
Yeah.
You know what,
dude?
MMM.
Two things I would tell you when your brother,
first of all,
don't fucking hit on women.
You're around your fucking country brother.
And if he does pull some shit like that,
uh,
you know,
you've got to do something.
This is what you gotta do to that guy.
What you have to do is the next time he's hitting on a girl,
you have to deliberately go over and fuck it up.
You got to figure out some way to fuck it up.
And what you're doing here is you kind of shoot shooting one across the bow just
to let them know that if he does that shit to you again,
that there will be like repercussions.
You know what I mean?
And then just get the fuck away from the guy and continue on.
You know,
you're doing fine.
Right?
You had no problem walking up to the girl.
He had a strategy.
You're good.
But yeah,
there's no,
there's no sense.
Dude.
You're 20 years old,
man,
you're in fucking mint condition.
He only some fucking 26 year old we need to do with that.
Right?
I know you'd fuck her.
Exactly,
but you're not going to marry you,
right?
You don't have any feelings for so fucking fuck around and fuck your brother
fucking 20 or 21 year old cop cop were at the mall.
How did he,
how long do you have to go to school to be a cop?
You know?
Anybody else have that like you went to,
there's a kid in the grade above you and he's like the biggest maniac ever and
then you become a senior and next thing you know he's coming in,
he's breaking up keg parties and you're like,
dude,
I was in shop class with you six months ago.
Now I'm a police officer now.
Wow.
Well full on.
You've got the gun and everything.
I think I just missed a fucking unbelievable game doing this God damn podcast.
It was two scores late in the game.
You know what I hate about football?
I hate how they always show the Douche bags who dress up like they're going to
the rocky horror picture show.
You know what I mean?
I went to a Raiders game.
Not everybody is dressed like a douchebag and make no mistake.
Those are douchebags.
Okay.
Those people who fucking make a hat out of a football,
you know they did it the Patriots game too.
I was joking with my buddy,
I go,
can't they just show some regular fan who looks like he has season tickets?
It could actually talk about the game.
This guy had like a,
you know,
silver glitter on his face with the Patriots.
Amble people wearing football helmets to the game.
You know,
it's almost like the guy in the TV truck is just telling the cameraman,
just find the biggest douche bag you can find.
That's who we're going to show.
I went to,
I went to a Raiders game uncle a couple of years ago.
Man It was,
it was great.
You know,
just a legendary place.
Even though it's been a while since they've had a lot of success.
They did go to a Superbowl,
gets Tampa Bay a few years ago,
but I actually met this older guy,
man.
He had like the Ken Stabler silver and white beard at some booze on his breath.
You know,
he's a football fan.
If I wasn't sitting there dressed like Boba Fett is fucking dumb.
I hate people do that shit.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
Bill,
I was bored and thought I might give you something to think about.
I live in Europe and would love to move to the u s but I have no idea how to
even apply or even if it's a good time to do it.
I'm 30 and I've been stalling for years,
but I don't want to pack a bag and just end up as some homeless guy in the
corner in America.
I've always loved New York as the idea,
as the idea of this,
that city.
What as the idea of a city that never sleeps fits me.
Um,
as I'm a little older now,
I've already seen most of my friends friends leave into the domestic lifestyle
and I just can't fit into that yet.
I spent a lot of time alone for a few years and it's just like your act,
you start going a little crazy.
Um,
I feel like an observer in life,
so I do and say stuff just to see what happens sometimes.
Would it be,
sorry,
I'm scrolling down here.
It would be a good ground.
Would that be a good ground for comedy maybe?
Or should I have started in my twenties.
I also play guitar and people have said I might have something musically for
years,
but I was always a coward in my youth and couldn't get on stage unless I was
hammered.
So I never got anywhere.
Now I'm worried I lost too many screws and as my social network has begun
failing,
I just get the bitter alone against the word world feeling.
It feels like I'm at a crossroads.
Everything I've seen in life seems like a weird dream and I'm surrounded by
strangers.
What do you think?
I think that's pretty fucking deep.
Um,
what is,
well,
if you're not married,
you don't have any kids and you want always wanted to move to New York,
just fucking do it.
Save up some money and just do it.
You're never going to regret,
you know?
Or if you live in America and you're like,
Hey,
I always want to go to Paris,
what would happen if I just fucking went there and do it?
The very least.
You just got to get some great stories.
You know,
you're going to come over wherever you're going to go.
You're going to have an accent.
You're gonna Hook Up.
It's going to be a good time.
I would definitely say to go and don't mind fuck yourself into thinking you're
too old to do shit.
Look failing.
The uh,
uh,
how do we put this?
Failing is like overrated is far as like the pain that people have.
It's not doing it because I have a lot of fucking regrets in life.
I got a lot of fun in regrets.
I'm not going to get into them,
but I got a lot of fucking regrets and I've failed a lot as a comedian,
but none of them really hurt cause I just kept doing it.
You know?
Remember that old Michael Jordan commercial where he talks about shooting the
basketball is all the shots he's missed.
He's like,
I failed over and over and over and over again and that's why I succeed.
You've got to take that mentality,
dude.
Failing is fucking hilarious.
Failing is,
it's the best stories.
It's the funniest fucking stories.
Watch when people,
when actors go and they do panel on talk shows,
they never talk about,
you know,
oh I did this.
The bad guests go on there and talk.
Oh,
I work with this director.
Oh my God,
he was so great.
But the good guests go on there and they talk about bad auditions that they had
or stupid things that they did in the great movie that they're promoting.
That's what the fuck you do,
you know,
to kill as a guests.
Look at me,
I'm too little tired.
I'm,
I'm making a different point now.
Now I'm telling you how to kill doing panel even though I've never fucking done
it.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
move to New York.
You're not gonna be homeless.
It's like a big river and you just jump in and you just start swimming.
But from the outside it looks impossible.
But once you go there,
you fine.
You know,
and if you do end up homeless,
fortunately it's a walkable city,
so there's plenty of people to panhandle.
Although if you're white,
you might have a rough time.
At least.
I did.
Did it one day as a joke just to see what people would do.
I was dressed really nicely and I just had a cup.
Excuse me sir.
Sir,
could you spare a little change?
Just trying to get home,
try and make a phone call.
But I had a shit eating grin so I didn't make any money.
All right,
next question.
I'm plowing ahead this week,
people.
Uh,
all right.
Hey Bill,
I'm a huge fan.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right.
You won't be after this low energy podcast.
Um,
throughout my life,
no matter what I've done,
I've,
I am known for being a horrible child.
All right guys,
let's stop here.
Uh,
just,
let's just remember that I barely got out of college and I have a communications
degree.
So let me communicate with you right now and let you know if you guys are going
to go real deep.
Cause I had somebody sent me like one,
they were like suicidal and uh,
I kinda didn't touch it because a,
I didn't want to give the wrong advice.
I was going to say go talk to somebody quite qualified,
you know,
and don't kill yourself.
All right,
so let's try it.
Let's,
you know,
let's,
let's back off the throttle a little bit here.
People,
this is supposed to be a funny podcast.
All right.
The Light Guy,
just walking around feeling like it's a dream and I'm alone.
You know,
I,
that's when it starts getting like,
all right,
I've had those thoughts.
Well,
I guess I've had those thoughts so I can relate.
You know,
I've thought about killing myself.
A lot of people think that shit,
you just don't do it.
You know what I mean?
It's like leg sweep and a chick.
You think about it,
you just don't do it.
But if someone makes a video of it,
you fucking watch it.
And it's hilarious.
Um,
all right,
let's plow through here.
Throughout my life,
no matter what I've done,
I've always been known for being a horrible child.
All right?
This guy has gotten right to the root of his pain no matter what I did.
It wasn't good enough.
Um,
I think I'm a pretty and I feel bad cause I'm be making fun of people as they're
fucking really opening up here.
So let me stop doing that.
All right.
Uh,
I think I'm a pretty good kid compared to,
uh,
the people.
I know my grades aren't that good,
but hey,
I haven't gotten held back as a positive way of looking at it.
You got a D in math?
Yeah.
Did I stay back?
Well,
I write then shut the fuck up.
I'm 15 and I have an older brother,
two years older and I have a younger brother,
two years younger.
Uh,
the younger one is annoying.
So if he starts bothering me,
I say something to him telling him to stop.
Uh Oh,
when I do that,
I'm being a dick.
What?
When I could just slap him with something and then he does the classic shit and
screams like clockwork and my parents will come in and punish,
make,
oh yeah,
dude,
I've been there.
I had three younger brothers.
Um,
if he was bothering me first or if he,
he,
they punish you if he was even bothering you first.
Um,
or what you gotta do is you've got to muffle his voice with a pillow or he can
go the opposite route is you can torch room by tickling them is basically you
sit on their arms and you do the typewriter thing.
You know what I mean?
Does a lot of other ways to make,
obviously the slap isn't going to work cause he knows he's going to get you in
trouble that way.
So you've got to come up with creative ways to torture your younger brother.
Start with doing it when your parents aren't home.
All right.
Why am I telling people to do this shit?
Uh,
let me go and at some point they need to stop babying him instead of taking his
side because he's the youngest.
And then there's my somewhat perfect older brother who was always in the
limelight.
I admit,
I'm jealous.
I mean,
he makes honor roll plays football and works all at the same time and I'm just
the fuck up in the middle.
Why is it middle kid always feel fucking neglected I guess cause you're in the
middle.
I was,
you know,
second oldest.
I don't know where the fuck I was.
Um,
he has always been treated better than me.
I'm his best friend got him in trouble for,
for lighting trash cans on fire back when he was in the seventh grade and my dad
cursed him out and told him to never hang ultra cursed out the other kid and
told him not to hang out with my older brother again.
Uh,
what happens in the 12th grade?
I'm there hanging out again and my parents don't say shit.
I have a bad friend and I haven't even gotten in trouble with them,
but my parents won't let me hang out with them.
My parents let my older brother learn how to drive when he was 12 and I'm
turning 16 and they haven't taught me shit.
I probably won't get it damn license until I'm 25.
Then they treat me like shit.
Last week I cleaned my bathroom and left,
uh,
my mini trash cans sitting outside the bathroom.
And instead of being glad they go,
wait,
because I leave the trash can outside the bedroom.
Please tell me what you think about this situation.
Um,
yeah,
you're getting the middle child treatment.
You get in the middle child treatment and this is what I would say,
beat up your younger brother when your parents aren't around or maybe break some
of his shit when he's not in his room and a,
your older brother,
uh,
you can cut the brake lines on his car.
Now I'm fucking with you.
Um,
uh,
you know what?
Fuck them.
If they don't want to pay attention to you,
fuck them.
Just keep doing your thing.
And I make a joke out of,
you know,
you know you left a trash can outside the bathroom.
I know.
What was I thinking?
I should have been like my older brother and lit it on fire.
You're absolutely right.
At what point did you realize you were bored with me?
Huh?
When the newer version of me came along
and then when she tries to interrupt you speak now dad,
dad,
I get it.
You don't care.
You don't.
I'm the Middle Kid.
What do you think?
I don't watch the Brady bunch.
I saw what Jan went through.
I'm going through the same shit.
Then bring up that shit about driving.
Huh?
How bad a driver was my older brother that you just decided not to teach any of
us,
you know,
I dunno.
Just go with that route.
But you know [inaudible] don't take it personally.
Just focus on your own life.
You've got to understand,
you're probably walking around 15 you know,
you know,
you're at that age where you kind of think he knows some shit,
but you kind of know that you don't know a lot of other shit,
that that feeling never goes away and your parents are walking around thinking
the same shit,
so don't take them too seriously,
you know,
unless they tell you,
you know not to do drugs or hang out with that Douche bag,
you probably shouldn't be hanging out with them.
But you know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't want it to tell you dude.
It's like that shit that you're going to get through.
It gets better when you're in your twenties you know,
and you never know.
Your brother might have peaked that AMsuite a lot of people,
you know,
if they get in fucking late in high school,
like do you want to say,
and how great your life is.
If you're actually on the football team and you're fucking a cheerleader in high
school,
I mean,
I don't know how you ever beat that.
You have to become like a fucking movie star.
Like there's nowhere for those people to go.
That's why so many of those people,
they,
when they go out in the real world,
they fail because they've always been,
I mean you king of the world,
you're on a football team,
you're banging a cheerleader,
right?
You both in your teens,
your bodies are in mint fucking condition and you don't have to pay rent.
And if you do some dumb shit,
you're still charged as a juvenile.
I'm going to tell you right now,
it's never going to get better than that.
Okay.
Are you going to go a long fucking way as an adult to make it better than that?
Okay,
so you know,
I don't know if I'm sharing,
you're up here,
but you know,
being in the middle of being in that mix is not a bad fucking thing.
Being in the middle of the herd.
Cause then you can break out,
you can try to figure out what you want to do and then the fact that people kind
of Shit on you,
you get a good sense of humor.
You already wrote some funny shit.
You'll be fine.
You are,
fuck your older brother and your younger brother.
What do you think about that?
I know what to tell you,
dude.
I just don't want to fuck you up,
I don't,
I don't have the background to give a 15 year old fucking advice.
I really don't.
But I hope I made some sort of sense,
but don't take it too seriously.
All right.
You know what I would do?
I would always clean the bathroom and always leave the trash can out there just
to deliberately annoy your parents and then act slightly retarded to the point
that actually think back to some drugs that they did when they were single.
And that's why you're fucked up now,
you know,
do some shit like that.
Just passive aggressive stuff.
Started having fun with the fact that they don't pay attention to you.
In other words,
act out.
That's what I'm trying to say.
All right,
so let's recap.
Break a younger brother's shit.
Cut The brake lines and your older brother's car.
Ignore your parents and act slightly retarded.
All right,
that's my advice.
Um,
oh,
here's something for you.
I got good.
I wrote a,
I got good feedback from a woman.
I don't get this very often and said,
hey bill,
just wanted to comment on your response to the guy who got shot down at the
sandwich shop a couple of weeks ago.
That was a loaded question and for what it's worth from a female fan,
I thought your answer was incredibly fair as well as funny.
It is bullshit that men generally have the burden of approaching women and I
know that burned is asked to have her look at him like a disgusting chore,
but just because She's pretty,
doesn't mean she owes everybody whoever tits on her a fucking thank you card.
I really appreciate your answer.
You could have gone a much easier and shittier root.
Thanks.
Yeah,
you mean like how he did with the 15 year old kids question.
All right.
Every once in a,
I get positive feedback feedback from a female,
so I got to read it.
All right,
next one.
I'm just going to read this like a book this week.
People,
I'm literally nodding off here,
uh,
asked bill,
hey bill.
Uh,
throughout my life to matter.
What I've done,
and I already read this
already,
read this one,
right?
Jesus Christ.
All right.
Oh,
here's some letters from people overseas,
specifically England.
This section's called English cunts.
Hey,
built.
So he thought my last email wasn't good enough for your podcast.
I hold no grudges.
It's a recession and you want to keep it all American fair play.
So let's keep up the theme from your last one in attempt to get a mention,
a shameless whoring of myself here.
I,
you say baseball jumped the shark.
Let me tell you something.
Coming from the nation that pretty much invent,
invented all major sports except the Olympics.
Great Britain.
You know,
I like to consider myself knowledgeable about sports.
Uh,
exactly what sports did you create?
What sports did you create?
You can do the rugby thing and then rugby developed into football.
I'll give you that one.
That,
that was the spawn of it.
But you can't take credit for baseball.
What do you say?
That's cricket.
You guys sit there with that fraternity paddle from some horrific night of
hazing.
You finally pulled it out of some freshman's ass and now you're trying to hit a
racket ball over to some guy from fucking India.
Huh?
What other sports have you guys invented?
Basketball.
You didn't invent that.
I don't know what you guys invented,
but you're sure suck it all of them.
You know when was the last time you guys won a World Cup?
You know what?
That's a great fucking question.
That's what you guys are known for soccer,
right?
And rugby.
Like when those douchebags over in England tried to,
they always try to say that that foot football players are pussies because they
were like helmets and that type of shit.
And then you watch a rugby game.
Those guys are tough.
But those guys would be hitting each other a lot.
Fucking harder if they had pads on and shit.
You know,
I watched the game.
He,
it's a bunch of guys fucking stick in their heads up each other's asses as
they're kicking out a football.
That's definitely,
and I know,
you know what's funny is I never disrespect rugby.
I look at it like that.
That's a tough sport.
And tough guys play that sport.
I don't know why they always pick on football.
I don't get it.
You know what I mean?
Dude,
Ray Lewis would fuck up at least five of your rugby players by himself without
pads.
You got nobody in your fucking little pussy ass English rugby league that looks
anything like Ray Lewis let ray Lewis would destroy him.
Jack Lambert,
once you bring them,
bring me your famous fucking rugby guys and show me how those guys are hitting
any harder than Lawrence Taylor.
You're out of your fucking mind.
Out of your fucking minds.
Let's look up England,
England.
World Cup victory.
I'm going to make a guess and I'm going to say it's,
it's somewhere.
It's gotta be the 1960s or before
England World Cup victory.
The World Cup victory by England.
1966.
There you go.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it was going to be back then.
Like when the Celtics were winning all their championships.
Right?
Was Brazil not allowed in back then?
Fucking pat in your stats.
Um,
I'm just fucking with you guys.
I respect your sports,
but I ate out.
Oh what?
What are you pretty much eventually all major sports except the Olympics.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You guys didn't invent shit.
You had a half ass idea that we made.
Tremendous.
Is there any,
you know what I mean?
Like the greatest fucking soccer player of all time.
He's,
is he from England?
Palae the Michael Jordan of soccer is not even from England's.
Why don't you guys dominate something on a world fucking level?
I want what,
what,
what was the last time you guys had an athlete?
Cause I'll tell you right now that good looking son of a bitch for the La Galaxy
is not doing shit and nobody gives a fuck about him over here.
You can walk up and buy a ticket.
All right.
I,
Oh to La Galaxy fucking game.
I parked right next to the guy.
I didn't even recognize him.
Okay.
I asked him which way the fucking stadium was.
The only reason why I knew he was on the fucking galaxies cause he already had
his fucking cleats on.
All right.
He can't wait to go back there.
Um,
all right to fuck Bob Beckham.
All right.
Let me,
let me get back to this fucking thing.
I think I come from some authority.
Oh yeah.
Once you pat yourself on the back a little more.
Your English [inaudible] here we go.
Baseball always fucking sucked.
No it didn't.
And I'll tell you why it's a game suited for America like no other hours of time
to kill between meaningful play.
Meaningful for some reason is two words.
Meaning full,
like what is the meaning of the word and IAA.
Too much.
Um,
full meaningful is one word.
Get Dumb cunt.
Take the last l off the full and smash them together.
Jesus,
I hope that's right here.
I just made an ass out of myself.
Uh,
between meaningful,
um,
play,
allowing for re the required TV,
advertising and selling of Shit.
Overpriced food and poor beer out.
Jesus Christ.
Really?
You don't have any advertising there.
There's advertising all over the fizz advertising on the fucking ball in
England.
You know what?
Maybe if you guys scored more than once every fucking 90 minutes,
you know what I mean?
You could stick some commercials in there.
Jesus Christ,
that soccer is like hockey without the skates and the scoring and the fighting
and everything.
That makes it great.
You have to see like a little sissy get tripped out and I don't know,
during recess and he rolls around in the ground.
It makes such a big fucking deal out of it.
You want to beat him with his own books.
That's what like watching soccer is like every five seconds.
These guys,
they look like if,
if Pau Gasol,
if you could have like whatever 20 power saws all in the same fucking field,
just bitch and Moan and with that crybaby fucking face,
that's what soccer is.
See what you did,
dude.
I actually really enjoy the game,
but you're attacking my shits and I gotta attack yours.
Um,
minimal athleticism required.
Yeah,
dude,
really hitting a baseball is one of the hardest thing you'll ever do.
Why don't you fucking brush your teeth and give it a chance?
At some point you guys are swinging with that big fucking paddle
can.
All right,
let me go.
You know,
I would never make fun of the bicycle kick and act like that's a simple thing to
do anyways.
And before you come up with this stock,
we'd like to see you face a hundred mile an hour curve.
I just did that.
That's hilarious.
From insert drugged up goon here and then talk that shit.
It's a game.
Not a sport.
Like bowling is a game
now.
It isn't.
I can see a bowling's a game.
It's just you standing there.
If somebody was throwing the bowling ball at your head at a hundred miles an
hour and it was fucking changing speeds,
then that would be a sport.
Okay.
Or if he just held the ball like tee ball,
you just hit it off the stand.
Then it would just be,
that would just be a game.
I Dunno.
Athlete athletes or people who actually move around for the majority of the
sport cyclists,
rowers,
even soccer players cover around 10 k per game.
Oh God.
Really?
Is that why they were all built like women,
you know what your athletes look like and fucking England.
They look like mannequins at the gap.
You know.
I know we're fat over here,
but we're more muscular to you.
Fucking pansies over there with your poor nutrition in your nationwide
healthcare plan.
Why don't you get some fucking protein in your diets?
The skinny ass fucking arms and your little legs running around,
not being able to,
you know why you can't use your fucking hands in soccer?
Cause you fags would break your wrists.
All right,
that was homophobic.
Sorry about that.
They mean to say fag.
Sorry.
Just get worked up.
Anyways,
let's come.
Let's finish this.
The game comes from an old English game of rounders,
which was buying larger game of women.
The fuck is he talking about now?
You know,
I don't even give a shit anymore.
Whilst me,
we,
me were,
while the real me,
we're playing rugby and football.
What?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You're trying to say baseball was made up by a woman.
Is that what you're trying to say?
You know what?
I love?
Everybody acts like they fucking hate America and they can't stop paying
attention to us.
I don't listen to any English douchebags podcast.
You know?
I don't know a fucking thing.
I know Tony Blair,
Tony Blair bitched up and fucking sent you guys,
you know,
got you guys into fucking Iraq too.
Cause he didn't have any balls.
You know why?
Because he plays soccer.
Wow.
That was really fucking mean.
Alright.
Underrated.
Check out this Scottish comedian Frankie Boyle.
Very dark but funny Scottish guys are fucking hilarious.
Um,
I look forward to your non [inaudible] non reply and if I do get past your
filtering process,
fucking up reading this out loud.
Well I did all of that.
I don't have any filtering process.
I read all of these goddamn things.
I have nothing better to do.
Where are we in this podcast?
44 fucking minutes.
All right,
let's get to some overrated,
underrated.
Um,
what the fuck are we going?
All right.
Overrated.
Uh,
okay.
Overrated drummer Neil Peart.
Now before all the prog rock tech heads,
start quoting modern drummer here me out.
We've had the technology since the 1960s to program a computer to play poly
rhythmic beats.
Try having garage band play Elvin Jones or Rashied Ali.
I don't know who that is.
Um,
dude,
you can't say that man.
Those are different kinds of drums.
Although I'm not really into Neil Peart.
I'm not until,
I think he's,
I don't know.
He's just too fucking on the beat.
He sounds like a robot.
He's fucking amazing.
But uh,
I like,
I dunno,
I think people either like John Bonam.
Oh,
you like Neil Peart.
You know what I mean?
Nobody gives a fuck.
They're not drummers.
All right.
Um,
I think that's it.
I think that's going to be it for the podcast.
Um,
as I'm fucking trying to get a Gig in England.
I just fucking trashed everybody over there.
I'm just,
you know,
everybody just fucking trash in American non fucking stop now.
And then you go to their countries and eno,
you see Fat Fox,
you see losers.
I don't know what they're bragging about.
I really don't.
They talk about how amazing their beer is.
I gotta admit I went to Sweden,
they did some good beers,
man.
A couple of beers from,
uh,
actually had one from Czechoslovakia,
some checks assumption that still doesn't even exist anymore.
The Czech Republic,
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know.
That's another thing that bugs me about Europeans.
They think they're so fucking worldly cause they know all about Europe and shit
and it's like Europe is like basically the size of half of America.
So if you know something about the state next to you that's the same as like
somebody from England,
no one about France.
I mean you can fucking drive there at this point.
It's really not impressive,
but it is beautiful over there.
Whatever Hitler didn't bomp bomb and is still left standing is very nice.
Um,
all right.
I was a little cunty this week just cause I was tired.
Uh,
blame it on that.
Um,
and I think that's it.
I think that's all that I have to say this week.
Uh,
I just want to thank everybody for the tremendous turnout,
the tremendous turnout in Philadelphia.
I actually had to stay an extra day and at a show that was awesome.
Um,
let me hype,
my show's coming up and I don't you English costs get all pissed off of what the
fuck I say because I don't even read half the shit that you guys,
right.
You know,
calling me up,
telling me if I talk about American sports,
it's boring as if I give a flying fuck,
you know.
All right.
Let me get to my website and obviously I can give a fuck.
I'm bringing it up.
Um,
and I also,
if you,
if you're just trying to write shit to Piss me off,
it's going to work because I have to respond to everything because I have that
disease where I have to make my point.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the,
uh,
what I got coming up.
Um,
not this weekend.
Next weekend I'm going to be the Improv in Addison,
Texas.
Uh,
September 24th,
25th,
26th.
And I'm also the Sunday.
Is that the 27th?
I think I added the day cause I'm hanging around going to the cowboys game.
Let me see here.
Uh,
checking out the calendar.
Yeah.
And the 27th,
I'll be there Thursday through Sunday,
we added a Sunday show.
I'm going to be there.
God damage to bring your friends down and I'll see you at the cowboys' game on
Monday.
Then on,
um,
October 2nd,
third and fourth,
I'm going to be at the stress factory in New Brunswick,
New Jersey.
And,
uh,
the following weekend I'll be at the Improv in Pittsburgh and all the rest of my
dates are up my website.
I want to thank everybody for a,
all the great support.
I've really had a tremendous last couple of gigs here,
you know,
going into Atlanta,
over to Stockholm,
Sweden,
and then down to Philadelphia.
Really tremendous turnout.
I really appreciate it.
And,
uh,
all you guys basically out there asking me when I'm going to come to your
country,
you know,
Australia,
New Zealand,
I'm working on that shit.
I'm going to,
uh,
try to put some,
youtube videos up on a,
I discovered when I was in Stockholm,
Sweden,
that youtube,
you know,
there's like literally just like Wikipedia,
you know what I mean?
There's all kinds of different youtube,
I just stuck with the English one because I'm a fucking American surrounded by
people speaking English and water.
But,
uh,
I'm going to try and get some shit up on maybe the Australian one.
The England will English one or whatever.
I guess evidently that's a way to build a following over there.
So hopefully I can travel over there and maybe I'll check out some of your
sporting events and maybe I'll change my opinions,
but you know,
something,
I would be way more open to enjoying sports from England or someplace else.
If you could just tell me about them without fucking trash in,
you know,
American sports first.
If you just want to hear me flip out,
then by all means continue what you're doing because it's working.
All right?
But,
uh,
you know,
hey,
no disrespect to your troops that went over to Iraq too.
You know,
I just wanna make sure I didn't get a little out of hand there.
All right.
This is all jokes,
so don't send me any fucking hate mail.
All right.
That's the Monday morning podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody for listening.
And,
uh,
I know there was one other fucking per thing I didn't get to.
Maybe I'll get to it next week.
Wow,
that's it.
That's it for the podcast.
Everybody have a great week.
[inaudible]
doormat stay
[inaudible].